autrefois les territoires du nord est
est le royaume des vikings
ces grands guerriers au courage
légendaire règne sur la mer comme sur
terre
l'un d'entre eux se distinguaient
particulièrement par sa force et sa
valeur
le vainqueur du tournoi de tir à l'arc
guen le droit de naviguer avec les
vikings et grâce à ça ce sera noël
vainqueur magnifique tu auras ta place
sur le drakkar
rien ni personne ne t'oblige à être un
guerrier viking comme ton papa
c'est sûrement les pédos da j'ai
découvert ça on dit qu'elle a le pouvoir
de changer toutes choses en ordre
[Musique]
elle qui avait à coeur aux morts
maintenant tout le reste est en or toute
seule ici à pouvoir nous sortir de cette
galère
bravo rails
où vas-tu maman je te promets
je vous souhaite la bienvenue
portent l'épée là-haut avant qu'il ne
soit trop tard
ça sert à quoi un grand vikings pour
l'éternité
en fait je sais comment me sortir désir
sauf le peur mais l aventure c'est dans
nos cordes les copains
maintenant rang moi mon épée d'abord tu
me dis qu'elle est at war montre-moi le
ticket de caisse
[Musique]